bitcoin crossing 50 000 we're gonna
start we have a bunch of charts and
tables here for you we've got the price
chart of bitcoin which shows that
through the beginning of this year or
i'm sorry over the last 12 months
remember we were only at 10 11 000
uh a year ago so we have gone from about
ten thousand dollars one year ago to
today we're sitting around 50 000
when you look at the
return on this asset it is absolutely
nuts
go from 10 000 to today now if we go and
we actually look at bitcoin versus
traditional assets the return on
investment you can see bitcoin up about
364 percent gold is down eight percent s
p 500 plus 27
but if you go all the way back five
years bitcoin up eight thousand four
hundred percent video game numbers and
then ten years it's up almost seven
hundred thousand percent gold sucks down
three percent and the s p 500 up 281
pretty incredible then we can look at
the bitcoin price closing history by
level all of this data comes from
casebitcoin.com it's one of my favorite
websites on the internet casebitcoin.com
uh the bitcoin price closing history 71
days bitcoin has ever been above 50 288
when i screenshotted this this morning
that's right i was doing work that is
only
1.5 of bitcoin's life has ever been
higher than where it is today so for
98.4
of bitcoin's life
it has been lower than it is today
now if we then go and we look at bitcoin
versus the select indexes and assets
what we can see on this chart is a whole
bunch of different statistics so we can
see from a market cap standpoint bitcoin
still right under a trillion dollars
gold just over 10 trillion it's about
10x bigger the s p 36 trillion and the
nasdaq 21 trillion so bitcoin is
materially smaller than the rest of
these assets the 24 hour volume though
on this asset compared to let's say a
gold is that bitcoin has seven billion
dollars in 24 hour volume the inflation
over the next year bitcoin has slightly
higher inflation than gold the inflation
over the next 10 years bitcoin is going
to be much much slower than gold and
then the return on investment over a one
year period is just bonkers bitcoin up
363 percent gold down 7.5 rounded to 8
the s p and nasdaq both up about 27
and tlt the u.s treasury's down 10
over one year compound annual growth
rate over the 10 year period bitcoin 142
compound annual growth rate over the
last 10 years given where the price is
today gold down lost the compound annual
growth rate of gold for the last 10
years is negative absolutely pathetic
the 14 and 20 for s p and nasdaq
volatility gold is the least volatile
volatility is not good or bad if it goes
in your favor it's good if it goes
against you it's bad bitcoin is the most
volatile which is actually a good thing
because it's going up it's going in the
favor of the bulls not the bears and the
sharp ratios this is really important
when you start to think about
the portfolio construction bitcoin by
far has the highest sharp ratios of any
of these assets and so when you look at
that it begs the question why has
bitcoin continued to perform so well so
of course if we want to understand
bitcoin we understand what's happening
let's go to the wizards first we've got
the young wizard will clemente he had a
great tweet uh uh was yesterday that
said coinbase buyers are back this is
the bitcoin balance on exchanges of just
coinbase so
this is uh you can see right there in
the middle of july we saw a bunch of
bitcoin coming on to the exchange that's
that gold line uh kind of accelerating
uh and then basically it came off but it
was a net gain still
in early august and then we've been
going sideways and then recently over
the last uh week of august or so there
was a very material drop in the amount
of bitcoin that was on coinbase uh and
again as we've talked about in the past
the more bitcoin that's on the exchanges
the more likely it is that people can
buy or sell or can sell it uh the more
bitcoin that is not on the exchange the
harder it is to sell therefore there is
less selling pressure on the actual
asset itself then if we go and we look
at my friend travis kling travis coming
out of the woodwork last night with a
great
thread one of the tweets he said
importantly the price appreciation of
bitcoin
recently from 30 to 50 000 has come
during a period of the lowest spot
volume in the last year last time spot
volumes were this low
was mid october of 2020 and bitcoin
price was around 11 400
we all know what happened next what that
means is bitcoin then went from about 11
000 to 64 000 over the coming five
months or so and so again history is not
a predictor of the future but
if history was to repeat in any form or
fashion or was to rhyme to some degree
it is likely that bitcoin is poising for
a massive move upwards so pretty
incredible to see such low spot volumes
right now even though bitcoin has gone
from 30 000 back up to 50. then he went
on and he had a second uh great point
where he pointed out and he said this
period of low spot volumes has also
coincided with a period of low realized
volatility for bitcoin as shown below
with the four hour chart bitcoin is
coiling there's a tendency to do this
from time to time what that means is as
the spot volumes have come down i mean
that people aren't buying on more retail
exchanges there's there's not that much
buying happening but price has still
continued to grind upwards uh and so
when that occurs the volatility is
shrinking down so you get this almost uh
coil right and uh it coincides with what
will would call more of like a supply
squeeze is you almost get this asset and
it's packing it's packing it's packing
it's back and then it explodes now
historically that explosion of movement
or that violence of movement can be up
or down right so it can work in both
ways but given what we're seeing with
the on-chain metrics it appears that
bitcoin is coiling for the supply
squeeze and is likely to move much much
higher uh and be quite violent now with
that said that doesn't mean it will
happen but when we look at the actual
bitcoin on chain about 80
of bitcoin is being held by illiquid
hands the people who have long term
strong hands who have a history of not
selling if you also account for the lost
coins that we know of so about 80
of the active bitcoin that is not lost
is being held by these long hands that's
in circulation and so when you get this
coiling uh kind of effect and you also
get the setup on chain for the supply
squeeze what it is likely to be setting
up for is an explosive end of the year
so joe john what do we think is a
kind of thing is there a counter
argument or just every single data point
we're looking at saying hey this is
setting up for just
absolute fireworks through the end of
the year yeah like i was reading an
article this morning and a lot of the
mainstream uh media websites are trying
to point out reasons as to why uh
bitcoin has crossed 50 000 for the first
time in a few months here uh other than
just briefly the other day
and a lot of them pointed to uh twitter
potentially integrating uh bitcoin as an
option for tip jar uh they pointed to el
salvador bitcoin going live as a legal
tender in el salvador but the end of the
day like these metrics tell the story
right and if you follow these it's
historically proven to be a very good
estimate and very accurate uh from the
point of price action so i think what
we're gonna see is we've seen
a lot of the other
digital assets whether it's ethereum uh
nfts other currencies whatever it might
be they've outperformed bitcoin for the
last uh you know couple months now uh
honestly and i think what we're gonna
see is we're gonna see bitcoin kind of
remind everyone what's going on here and
i think uh over the next three to four
months what will and some of the other
people that you mentioned are bringing
up is like this price action looks
really good and it's difficult to find
uh counterpoints within the actual data
on chain that says that we're not gonna
go meaningfully higher the only on-chain
metrics that over the last few weeks
appears to be somewhat negative or uh at
least uh could provide ammunition to
somebody who is bearish right now uh in
my opinion is exactly what will's been
saying which is the transaction volume
is down quite a bit it has been grinding
up a little bit um but the transaction
volume would also explain why there
isn't tons of spot volume there's tons
of volatility all that type of stuff so
i think it's all kind of intertwined
the other
argument i think you could say is that
the nfts all the smart contracts uh
platforms the solana's of the world all
of these other like shiny things that
have been moving up significantly appear
to be taking away some of the uh the
public conversation like the narrative
uh among a bunch of these uh folks but
when the king's ready to move ain't
nobody gonna forget who the king is
right i mean when you listen this
happens all the time where basically
bitcoin moves up then people rotate out
of bitcoin into alts right then the alts
kind of have the alt season and then all
of a sudden when it's time to move
everyone runs right back into bitcoin
and the thing explodes upwards and the
reason being because it has such a
significant um kind of liquidity to it
and when it decides to move there's just
so much more capital that can be put
into it so if you're a large institution
for a large organization you're much
more likely to go put it there than you
are to try to go pick you know some 10
billion or 1 billion dollar market cap
asset and hope that goes up what's up
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're going to be the best business show
we obviously need the best partner
that's why the exclusive sponsor the
best business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]